the agenda is set hello everyone I'm
Brent Gogh in Berlin today on the show
I'm getting a new neighbor barbie is
moving to Berlin and some people are
seeing red definitely not peek down with
the doll that in war today it's time to
talk there she is Berlin's newest
resident the barbie dreamhouse opens its
doors this week should you let your
little girl go inside and play today why
some people want barbie to pack up and
leave way it was a shocking opera people
booed walked out and some claim it made
them so sick that they needed to see a
doctor Wagner's opera ton heuser set in
a Nazi concentration camp a daring
interpretation that was shut down last
week after opening night the Opera House
boss said it went too far the director
is crying censorship and if you don't
wear glasses google plans to change that
and fundamentally alter the way we look
at our world they're called Google glass
spectacles with a built-in computer
screen and camera critics are calling it
stealth surveillance cafes cinemas
casinos are already banning it the
question is is your privacy about to end
where my nose begins well I've invited
three people today to talk argue and pry
apart these headlines my first guest is
part of a very privileged group that has
actually been able to wear Google glass
I'm happy to welcome to the show Tobias
varty is a blogger and Internet policy
spokesman for the Green Party here in
Berlin I'm Toby as you say Google glass
is like having street view in your
eyeglasses which is interesting we're
going to talk about the whole experience
a little bit later on but let's talk
about privacy for a second you say it's
not the people that are being watched
who you're worried about you say you
worried about the people actually
wearing these glasses you say their
privacy is most threatened why Google
glasses are a game changer its beginning
of the area of wearable computers and we
have to talk about what what happened
with our data by using these computers
and okay and the possibility of
everything we see of course being
recorded we're going to talk about that
in just a moment my second guest is as
we've said before part of the a-list in
classical music and art circles around
the world he has been on the show before
and he is a vogner fan I'm happy to
welcome back to the show mark Gisborne
he is an art historian by trade mark
were in a difficult position here we've
asked you to come on the show and talk
about this controversial stage
performance of vogner Steinhauser but
it's been banned and and we can't see it
are we talking about pure censorship
here well undoubtedly talking about
censorship but the question is is
censorship to the greater good so many
things that are censored in society and
unacceptable a question is is this an
acceptable case of censorship all right
we're gonna try it we're gonna try to
answer that in just a moment and my next
guest says that she will not be rolling
out the welcome mat for Barbie this week
here in Berlin she says Barbie promotes
unhealthy body ideals for girls and it
teaches them that they can only define
themselves through their looks I'm happy
to welcome to the show Stevie Shmi know
she is co-founder of pink stinks a
campaign that targets products and media
that stereotype the images of girls
that's correct Stevie you are also a
lecturer in gender studies and a mother
with two girls as well so you've got
something at stake here personally um
Stevie what is so bad about letting
girls play in a life-sized dollhouse
there's actually nothing bad about
letting girls played in life size doll
so how's the problem is or the question
is what does the storehouse look like
inside I mean in a normal house you'll
have perhaps the workbench that people
are working with or you'll have lots of
different rooms you can do things in the
Barbie house is about cat walking
cupcake back a cupcake baking and it's
very much about beautifying yourself
now normal doll's house are not only
about beautifying yourself okay so
what's inside is what bothers your all
right well a lot of people going to be
talking about those cupcakes I'm sure
this week it is a big moving week for
Barbie the iconic doll is getting two
houses this week and she is not in
Malibu anymore the barbie dreamhouse
experience opened in South Florida just
a few days ago to throngs of squealing
young girls 10,000 square feet of pure
pink in plastic now barbie is probably
in her jet right about now headed for
Europe her second house opens here in
Berlin this week but the welcoming
committee may look and sound very
different and it will not be pretty the
Barbie doll has been one of the most
famous toys in the market for almost 60
years but despite the dolls popularity
Barbie also has her detractors critics
say the doll sets an unhealthy beauty
standard for young girls Samba even go
as far as to say that Barbie promotes a
sexist world view I think it's the worst
combination there is between sexism and
capitalism and it's just making money
out of oppressing women but the
organizers of the barbie dreamhouse
experience in Berlin disagree they
maintained the event is about having fun
and after all what's wrong with that
Stevie Barbies been around for a long
time why protest now well we've never
had a life-sized doll's house of Barbie
I think if you would have to have this
ten years ago we would have been more
shocked I would have said things like
that only happen in UK or in the States
and Germany has been more critical of
capitalist ventures like that now we've
got the Barbie house and we've got to
beauty salons for five-year-olds and
Germany as well and my English friends
say what's your problem because we have
them at every street corner so we are
experiencing the same so what is the
problem I mean isn't that just one part
of providing entertainment for little
girls um well there are lots of
different ways to entertain it'll go
oles and the question is why does it
have to be pink and pretty girl but why
not because I us because we have figures
and Germany's that are pretty recent we
can basically say that 2006 seventy
percent of girls and Germany heard
absolutely ok about their bodies six
years later in 2012 it was only forty
seven percent meanwhile we've had an
explosion of advertising billboards
everywhere of outdoor advertising we've
had Germany's Next Top Model as a series
becoming incredibly popular and Top
Model products and products for the
children's play world with the top model
and toys for six-year-olds everywhere
now we've had a huge change in the toy
market over the last ten years it's
become even more pretty and pink ER
we've got princess lily see which is a
very actually anorexic looking little
fairy that is absolutely hip in
kindergarten and she actually never eats
anything but feeds her heard all her
other toys a lot and so it's basically
the the image of the perfectly slim
attractive little girl that has become
too prominent but shouldn't your beef be
with with maybe the advertising industry
and not with Barbie Barbies been around
for a long time and we are with the
advertising industry as well we have a
huge petition against the advertising
industry or the advertising German
advertising board at the moment telling
the advertising board that all the
advertisements that are hanging outside
in the outdoor world children consume as
well and we want to take want them to
take that seriously that little girls
are watching advertisements every day
that to show them and tell them beautify
yourself you're not slim enough you're
not beautiful enough and you're only
going to be successful if you're slim
and beautiful which is not true look at
angular matter well she's not energy
he's not a Barbie and she's not a barber
Stevie what are we saying this and she
said she is an especially in the job
market today we don't have loads and
loads of top models making money but
people who are in different areas yeah
I've got some numbers here for you maybe
you can explain what's going on back in
1992 guess we'll go back 20 years ago
the teen talk Barbie doll there was
there was a big recall
boycott in the US because this was a
Barbie doll that would talk and one of
the things she said was math is hard and
you had a lot of people saying that this
was solidifying the image of little
girls who couldn't do math and science
and they just wanted to be pretty that
was in 1992 there were all these fears
about girls falling behind in math and
science in high school now bring it to
2012 and the numbers are totally
different in education girls are now out
sprinting boys it's comprising sixty
percent of new college graduates they
are getting more and more advanced
degrees more and more PhDs and soon they
will surpass boys in math and science so
this negative Barbie effect seems to
have lost its its negativity if you will
while we're talking about the school
level here yes they are even surpassing
boys in mass these days and even at
university level we have more more girls
who actually I interested in technical
subjects but they don't actually become
and they don't go into the job market
that is technological we have in the job
security at the moment is in mint jobs
which is mathematics informatics and
technology and Natural Sciences but we
don't have enough women in that area we
only have ten percent of Engineers and
Germany we don't have enough physicists
and and and mathematic and students and
it's there where actually we can get
good jobs at the moment that pay a lot
of money ok so and are you saying if we
got rid of Barbie and then the dolls
that are patterned after her yes we'd
have all of a sudden more female
engineers working at siemens the top and
wish for children for girls is to become
either top model or actress it's that
what they see in popular culture every
day and it's that what is advertised to
them as a job that might give them
success and power let me pull in our
gentleman here on the on the panel a
mark are we doing girls a disservice by
giving them Barbie to play with I think
I would agree with Stevie that in the
last 30 years under consumer capitalism
since the 8th is where everything is
niche market
and very tightly focused in the
advertising business that she was that
she has been a negative influence but
you say earlier she was a positive role
models you have to understand that when
bar I'm the only one who's old enough to
older than Barbie share your pre bar
with three Bobby I mean she came out as
a doll that is coincides with the pill
in the late 50s when women were getting
out of the kitchen remember after the
war women were pushed back into into
domestic servitude largely and bribed
with electric kettles and refrigerators
so at a certain time in the early
sixties when she emerged she emerged as
an independent woman could determine her
own life she could choose to have sex or
not and not have the fear of
reproduction and she was celebrated for
all of this she was celebrated in the
sixties as a positive role model for the
new woman particularly the sexual
liberated woman that emerges in the
sixties but like all things over a
period she becomes commodified and the
ideas associated with her pass away is
it possible then that we're just seeing
a doll who is maybe outlived her
usefulness and we need to retire her
even when she was launched on let's say
the 60s when the pill came onto the
market 1960 the pill came onto the
market of 9660 was the year that Twiggy
the first very very slim model was on
the cover of the vogue it actually
ticket quickie said basically I can
choose whether I want to work now and I
can choose what I want to have children
but please still protect me the whole
insecurity of changing gender roles
produced an image of women to be very
very slim and to still basically say
protect me I'm some tender I can't do
all this and I think the whole
insecurities were living in we've only
had feminism for a few decades it's so
real with the early 60s but it also
coincides with must be stressed with the
notion of a free sexuality that emerges
in the late fifties you know women don't
talk about sex in the fifties so you
have the Kinsey Report you have all
these e very important but the moment
they allowed to talk about it they
become slimmer and slimmer so what does
that signal because basically very slim
women
to have children anymore they're not
sexual as such anymore they can't
produce the hormones well but they're
being told that they can do both aren't
they and this is part but isn't this
part of feminism they're being told that
they can have this this bombshell body
but at the same time go to university
Mary can have children have you know
this atomic family nuclear family and
after the children are born they can go
back and do yoga and in a year later
their have the body of an 18 year old is
this the other way around um they told
you can go to university and have all
these great jobs but the same time you
have to look great isn't that well
they're told they can have it all
Stephen isn't that isn't that what
feminism told us early on that women
should be able to have it all well they
should be able to have it all but why do
they have to have this very very slim
body but barbie of the last have you
recently had a Barbie in your house here
in Berlin sorry that she had become so
slim that you actually think her legs
are going to break when you hold her in
haha I mean I do I you have to grant you
that a study came out very recently that
said if Barbie were to be a real woman
today her ankles and wrists would be so
skinny that she would have to walk on
all fours her neck would not be able to
lift her head and her stomach would have
only enough room for half a liver and a
few inches of intestines um I mean
Barbie would be you know she would not
be pretty if she were real let me ask
Tobias Tobias you you know were born in
the 80s you know so you've seen
something totally different you said if
you had little girls now if you had a
daughter now you would not want to give
her Barbie why because i think this
puppet was not very we understood you
know it's a it's a symbol for for things
that the market want us to be for sure
Bobby can go to university but like
Stevie says she always has to look great
and I think that's not wrong if you have
to do but that's not what you want for
your dollars i mean you know you
probably you reflect the market right
now I'm to swell tobias because the
numbers show that sales for barbie have
stagnated in the United States fallen
fifty percent since the year 2000 so you
know Stevie maybe you know you
maybe on the right side of the argument
here but maybe the market is going to
take care of Barbie and get rid of her
but why has the market second agent
because my tailor has now launched the
monster high doll and that has basic
taking the share of the market well
doesn't that it looks like um lady gaga
right that's what they say it's kind of
patterned after and kids love lady gaga
she's real yeah she's at huge problems
of eating disorders over the last 20
years as she's repeatedly said and she's
doing actually very good work on showing
everybody like Angelina Jolie this
morning talking about her cancer
problems I think Lady Gaga it's very
good at saying look I have this body I
make lots of money because of it but
I've had eating disorders for the last
20 years so there is a problem with our
system what before we move on what's
your take on this announcement by
Angelina Jolie about having the double
mastectomy to prevent cancer it's a top
news story about something that she is
voluntarily having done with her body I
think it's very brave because the whole
image is built on being incredibly
beautiful not only she's also working
for UNICEF etc but on the whole she is
the image of beauty and perfection and
for her to talk openly about it means
what other people can talk about it as
well okay and I take it you will not be
taking your daughters into the Barbie
house this week when it opens in Berlin
you will be protesting right I will be
protesting together with other groups
and joining us okay we'll be seeing you
on the news for sure then all right
let's move on our next story is about
opera but you do not have to be an opera
fan to appreciate what has happened here
across Germany opera houses are marking
the 200th anniversary of richard
wagner's birth now vagner is considered
a genius at composing music and bringing
it to life on stage but he also has a
dark side he was an anti-semite and the
Nazis adopted him as one of their heroes
last weekend in the German city of
Dusseldorf a new interpretation of
vogner stun heuser came to life on stage
a medieval piece set in the Holocaust
with Nazi concentration camp guards and
gas chambers the audience was not
impressed
productions of the shed Wagner's works
have often been just as controversial as
the famously anti-semitic composer
himself renowned Jewish conductor Daniel
Barenboim came under intense criticism
simply for performing symphonic excerpts
from a vogner opera in Israel but a new
production of Tong hua in Dusseldorf has
raised the controversy to a new level
some members of the audience were so
shocked by what they saw that they had
to seek medical attention the theatre
has decided to pull the production and
will instead present the Opera in
concert version
but is that the right decision mark what
do you say is that the right position to
take music with no stage well I think
perhaps one should say those naivety on
the part of the directors obviously
choosing this frame the subject matter
you know using fascist settings it's not
a new thing task has been done many
times and done again recently by the
Scottish National Opera using the
context of Mussolini the question always
is is the setting appropriate to the
narrative not being able to see the
Opera I can't really say except i would
say that knowing the story of tannhauser
which is deals with themes of profane
and spiritual love and the conflict it's
a very late medieval tale I mean can't
eyes Tannhauser himself was a night
right in the 13th century but the cult
is built from really the leader Book of
the 15th inning and you know the
director has said basically is he wanted
to bring the story to a an era that
people can relate to you know he has
defended his concept he said that vogner
zlib reto as it stood was no longer
understandable to modern-day audiences
and he says after the reaction after
opening night he says we were put under
extreme pressure by the local press and
ignorant know-it-alls most of whom did
not even see the staging I mean we're
also trying to build an opinion here we
haven't seen the show but he's saying
that the people who called for his
interpretation to be banned also hadn't
seen the show well first of all I'd
contest the fact that fairy tales in and
of themselves or these sort of
narratives are inaccessible you only
have to go to the hobbit and Harry
Potter and countless modern updates of
fictional narrow white or even still
watches very fairy 200 these are still
accessible narratives but in the context
here it's the idea of Venus who is can
be seen as and if you like a medieval
fairy or an elf or she can be seen as a
pagan goddess
the idea that she's a Nazi guard it
seems a little implausible in a
concentration camp and that the
connection to the profanity of the
narrative is loaded onto the fascist
setting so is this a director who simply
went too far in trying to modernize a
work of honor or is it a director who
does not know his audience I'm not sure
it's a director that is really aware of
the implications within tannhauser
itself I saw a few years ago Peter
Grimes here at the commissure opera
which is about pedophilia or the subtext
of pedophilia and the fact that Britain
himself was gay and the themes one as a
dark current set in a East England
village by the sea but when it was done
here they did it as if it was I don't
know rimsky-korsakov Shahrazad her and
so so I mean the question is
plausibility and we're not in a position
to be able to judge that given the fact
that it was taken off almost a minute
okay and that is the problem right that
is the problem we can't watch it I'm
Stevie we were talking before the show
about this and you said the director
should he should have known that he was
dealing with dynamite if he was trying
to bring any type of Nazi theme and put
it on the stage why can't you do that
and I feel very strong about that as a
German and with a German history as
German have everything were very
reflective which think talk about you
know socialism at school for many years
and think Germans are still traumatized
by the Holocaust and either because
their families were involved in it on
the victim or the culprit side and it's
a very very tender very difficult
subject in Germany now I only saw the
few exits that we just saw and it
touched me emotionally incredibly and I
find opera is entertainment as
reflective as it can be and
entertainment is you can't illustrate
anything entertaining with the victims
of the Holocaust that's my opinion but
is the topic completely taboo it took me
it's what about you you're from a
different generation here is it
something that immediately offends you
know because I think Oprah is also a
political place and if we if we don't
talk about our past and about the things
I'm not dramatized because of the
Holocaust because I'm more traumatized
because we don't talk so often about it
and that I should feel like from a
victim nation I studied was a issue
alien student and Natalia in Italy and
that they made jokes about the Holocaust
all the time and we Germans were really
truck because we never would do
something like that so is this something
then that can be done on stages but just
not in Germany is that is that what
we're dealing with here so we haven't
clarified something we should have had
done at the beginning it's not an opera
Tavana they were never operas they were
called dramas and of course he developed
the code notion of the ghazan
transferred the total work of art opera
was the great art form because it
brought together all the answer music
staging setting painting and every
element sculptural elements were all
brought into opera so in his context
this is a drama the question is today
can we believe in the notion of a total
work of art is that a work of art that
can accomplish all the aesthetic
parameters of our feelings and
sensibilities we live in a much more
desiccated and fragmented world maybe
that but we can't we do that though
can't we bring in political topics and
then put them on the stage with without
the director being absolutely no [ __ ]
balance Scarpia in Tosca is a muscle ed
figure so you can do tasker very aptly
in the context of fascist Italy but you
can't do not cease in Holocaust onstage
and Germany isn't that the message we're
going here it may be the message the
general message but it's not the
specific message the specific message to
me is is the staging of this opera
appropriate to the tour this the stage
of this drama are appropriate to the
drama
and does it bring more to the drama than
it might otherwise contribute are there
two different issues I mean one is your
issue which is a very justified question
and the other issue is really can we do
this in Germany on stage and I would say
no we can't because we've got too many
people of the older generation
especially who are traumatized on the
victim on the victim side but also we
have people still trying to work at all
fruit she'll still trying to understand
retrievers I'll yes also but if I go
into the Holocaust Memorial in Berlin I
can hardly breathe it really touches me
and I find very very hard to comprehend
I think a lot of we were still trying to
comprehend what went on there in our
families generations back and of course
we're talking about it all the time and
I think it's important that we talk
about I think it's wonderful that it's
just huge Memorial we do we talk about a
lot we talk about on this show a lot too
and I wonder if we don't run the risk of
even fetishizing the past talking about
it so much that it loses its gravity
that it's almost a caricature of itself
I don't think so at all i think it's
something happened that I could happen
any time again it couldn't happen so
quickly again with an eternity in the
world now it is happening in the world
now and I think it's so important that
we all always concern that won't happen
again and that's why we have to talk
about and that's why we have to taboo it
in a certain sense as well elie wiesel
has has written that there is something
unique about the evil of the Holocaust
and because of that it can't be
represented for example in art on stage
or whatever a famous quote you know by
your door no there can be no poetry
after Auschwitz yeah and this quote is
the sort of leitmotif that dominates
German culture do you subscribe to that
mark amoebic no I think it's protic it
could be taken to extreme recent russian
singer who had happened to be in some
heavy he's an opera singer was playing a
character and because he had a had been
in a heavy metal band and add a swastika
on his chest he was sacked was very
exactly you know it's it's it could be
taken to absolutely medication
definitely go overboard but the fact
that was taking it so seriously does
work doesn't it I mean we'd have the NS
a-- process at the moment we do we are
very very strict with any tendencies
towards National Socialism
and I think it is important that we ok
perhaps we fetish sighs it perhaps that
is the right word but I think that there
should be a taboo around it should be
until I don't make this notion of taboos
that because I think that's just code
code language for censorship and
shouldn't directors be able to put
things on stage that do shock us I think
we have to work with this history and
and was openness you know at taboo is
always something interesting you're not
allowed to read Hitler's my comfy in
Germany you don't study it at school not
at the University and this is really sad
I did it and it only was was an American
professor and she teach me hitless my
account and then she teach me
Machiavelli's as a print principle and
it was really interesting at a
juxtaposition it's fascinating yeah but
i had to meet an American professor but
you had to go outside of Germany in
order to have that experience I think we
should see this oprah's and I'm not I
have no clue about art and if it's
necessary or not but it inspires us to
talk about I mean today we're talking
about just isn't yeah we're talking
about it and is it that a good in and of
itself that we're talking about it I
mean wouldn't you both agree with me
about it anyway that's what I think I
think we talk about it through other
issues through people being arrested at
the moment for crimes they did in the
Second World War we do it because of new
stage yes we do it because with middle
class and educated but the masses of
German people like the masses of most
culture yeah but it's presented in the
local newspaper no doubt built has made
some comment of it in the newspaper so
it is brought to the to their everyday
concern in trick me everyday common man
so I think we have to be a little self
analytical and self reflective when we
make our own comments about this no yes
but it was only Porter than the course
was stopped because that was protest
against it it wouldn't have been brought
two of those readers it would have state
with the middle class us otherwise well
regardless if he's gonna see it i mean
this this version we're not gonna get to
see any time soon but quickly marked
before move on do you think that this
has scared directors in the
german-speaking world that they
now in the future that they will not
even attempt to do something that could
no i don't think so i think it has the
opposite effect i think it provokes
directors but they may not use this
actual approach to tannhauser but they
may find other I mean you there are
themes within the devil in the long run
you know the vote on every time could be
see a sort of a Hitler figure of the
fascist God you know there are many many
aspects you know one thing I want to
just say is quickly corrected move on
yeah form and content you know the
notion in the anglo-saxon world if a
thing is about if its content is
pornographic then the form is
pornographic in Germany and in France it
is historically a thing maybe
pornographic in subject matter but its
form can still have qualities in the
presentation yeah well alright well
those subtle differences yeah they need
to be talked about more day they do all
right we need to move on we're going to
talk about something now completely
different a story on technology that is
giving us the power to watch each other
on stage or not on stage in a way that
we have never been able to do before do
you ever notice and I ask all of you
this when you're in a cafe in a train or
simply on the street how people have
their faces glued to their smartphones
well it is considered contemporary
communicating posture that's acceptable
now well that could be about to change
Google wants to put your computer your
phone and your camera all in a pair of
glasses the new gadget goes on sale
later this year but already it is banned
in many places in the US and Europe some
fear that Google glass will turn us all
into spies with no way to know who is
watching and recording whom google glass
isn't even on the market yet but there
are already countless calls to ban the
product Google is touting its new gadget
as a groundbreaking development in
miniaturization and wearable computing
but privacy advocates are ringing the
alarm bells google glass could make it
far too easy for people to make
surreptitious videos which can be
uploaded to the company's servers in an
instant google is no stranger to charges
of overstepping privacy boundaries from
street view too
gmail buzz and Google+ the company has a
reputation for culling information from
unwitting users of its many services is
google glass just another little chip in
our privacy firewall or will it tear it
down completely what do you say toby is
should we be afraid of google glass now
we shouldn't be afraid but we should use
this this pair of glasses to start
talking about our society and how we
want to live in a society that is data
room and that won't go away you have had
the privilege of actually wearing them I
mean there's a select group of people
around the world who have that privilege
right now and you you have had a set on
tell us briefly what's it like when you
actually turn them on yeah it wasn't my
path glasses i'm at robert scoble and US
tech blogger who went was a Petra
balloon and he gave it around no and it
was really fascinating my first thought
was just a pair of glasses it feels like
every pair of glasses but when you turn
on you getting a very new perspective of
a fking engines and what you can see you
know the first user cases I would say
try try to navigate with glasses twice a
street view Lou you see the Alexander
plant and then you see arrows that show
you the direction to your next starter
there so it's kind of like being in a
spaceship and you're navigating but
you're actually standing on the ground
right right it's like the streets like
street view in a way this is the first
thing that that we tried to navigate
yeah i mean the use cases there can be
positive use cases and i see a lot of
them there will be negative use cases
for sure and they're real yeah I don't
know but give me one positive 1 positive
you scared and a medicine student will
get these glasses on the next weeks or
so and what you want to do is he wants
to record his work you want to learn you
want to see what he did
from another perspective other students
can watch this video to I so students
can watch what he was looking at ok so
that uses a teaching guy all right
what's a negative experience from this
the negative experience would say I
would I was sit in a train and I see
Stevie and I don't know her and then I
do a background search I can try to do
yeah and what's to stop you two things
one thing doesn't say I yet and this is
a like a contract of our society that I
won't do that I could do that today
let's not talk about manners and and
people memorize what is going to stop
you from doing a check on Stevie if you
want to do that check nothing in that
mode yet but I can go home now and
search for a name and see photos of her
and what you do this is today but
there's something more sinister though
knowing that that I can sit across from
you without you knowing I can run a
background check while I'm looking at
you and I can also record what I'm
looking at as well I mean this is
something we haven't been able to do
before this is something that we took we
talked about the CIA and special ops
forces being able to do but now you know
Joe Blow man on the street is going to
be able to look at Stevie and do a
Barbie background check on her for all
we know right I kept but uh your team do
the two you know you invited me because
you saw a picture of me with that pair
of glasses so I was somewhere in this
very scary internet a photo of mine I
put it there for myself that somebody
else could do it too because other
people were made photos and you you were
looking at the name and my address and
and you did it without the pair of
glasses so I think which computer you
use a pair of glass are a notebook
that's not important and really the most
simple the laws are very good you just
have to enforce them at I even think you
don't have to modernize the law of
privacy in journey but what we have will
to do is about talk about behavior is
good do I want and what and this is the
second point who has my data has google
i have i oh well I think everyone's
gonna want it once it becomes affordable
I think when it goes on sale it's gonna
be what $1,500 so people aren't going to
expand space too expensive but
eventually it would become cheap our
YouTube worried about this sir I'm
incredibly worried we've got a very
prominent NGO in Germany called digital
courage and they award issue an award
every year a big brother abort and it
went to Google of course this year
because especially for those glasses
just imagine you have this
Alexanderplatz in front of you and you
have the different arrows to tell you
where to go but Google knows that you
love strawberries for example because
Google knows everything about you
because with the search engine and for
different things that Google has on your
computer it has a lot of data about you
so google tells you if you go right
you'll be at the next aldi and there'll
be have to have stressful fresh
strawberries on numbers so basically
especially with children who are not as
critical who were these glasses if they
become as cheap enough so children can
actually want them for the birthday you
can have marketing targeted at children
even more specified exactly which is
going to make it and the day barbie is
going to seem harmless compared to this
exactly no it is it I think it's very
dangerous especially because we don't
know will the darts data only be
transferred to Google once it is
switched on off on our has no other
methods to actually access the data and
that's a big discussion at the moment in
digital carriage and de guitarra gazelle
shaft which are two prominent NGOs and
Germany they actually focusing around
this problem nobody's focus and I think
it's not about doing what we have to
talk Google is just the first company
was a first product which isn't very
impressive from the technical point of
view what is oppressive how it changed
how we live together in the society and
so we can talk about Google but in five
years there will be the next thing from
a Chinese company from yahoo actually
the technology we need to be focused on
right which you have the outcome of the
outcomes is take know what google this
glasses the camera is worser than my
smartphone camera you know the
tori is very low I just can make a video
about season it's just all the logic
said but we're moving to the point where
things may be will be implanted where
that will become acceptable you can have
something put in your ear or something
put in your eye on that part so there
are sidewalks that people want to be
sidewalks there's the sky neuhausen he's
very popular and just texting he's on
every conference he wanted to have a
sidewalk I a cyborg eye so that were
part me I mean is that where we're
headed you know we also get information
coming from Google's top people and this
is something I wanted to ask you about
Stevie the head of Google said that
smartphones are emasculating that the
fact that we are constantly looking at
our phones has emasculated us and Google
glasses are actually allowing us to be
the men we should be enable each other
in the eyes and confront each other
funny that's that's and I guess that's
based and all has to do with the study
of Simon baron-cohen he's actually the
cousin of sacha baron cohen that the
media and Simon baron-cohen did a study
in the 80s that infants when they are
born and look more on male infants would
look more mobile ace Mobley's ingles
mobile via and and girls would look more
at faces this whole study has been
redone very often and it's completed
it's a joke basically there weren't
enough baby so they actually tested and
the way they the way they were tested is
not up to modern and scientific
standards so this whole study but it's
very prominent because it's a study we
love because it's the gender stereotypes
repeated I never thought there was
anything gender related to holding my
smartphone but anyway but that's whole
conversation is putting the cart in
front of the whole yeah then the fact is
what we're really talking about is
something much more important and that
is the complete blurring of public and
private space which is invading every
area of our culture and even worse we
have private manufacture masquerading as
public space take the sony centre you go
there you think this is a public space
it has nothing whatever to do with the
public they have no right of access if
they wish to keep people out they can
keep people out so this whole notion of
what is public
municipal and private and private and
private space is completely gone what
we're talking about that all the time
though mark about about the erosion of
the lines the separating lines and are
we going to have to you know welcome a
future eventually where there is no
difference between public and private
problem is that the proximal the law for
advertising were made before we actually
had public advertising before we had
that explosion of billboards that we
have outside so advertising says that a
common normal person should be able to
understand the advertisements but that's
not the advertising outside is targeted
at children and they can't understand
what's going on there that's got to do
so the laws have to be renovated we're
running out of time so you're saying the
walls have to be changed yes and they
can't be changed quickly enough because
technical innovation is just so far okay
faker the sort of determinism we consume
what we are is what we consume yeah is
completely dominant in this technology
around the world we're and we're gonna
have to wrap it up with that thank you
to all three of you and we will see you
later this week at the Barbie house here
in Berlin Stevie's that is that is going
to wrap up my agenda this week don't
forget you can watch the show again
online and don't be shy our inbox is
always open you can tell us what you
think about the show go to agenda
english at dwe stay tuned to DW I'm
Brent Goff in Berlin join me next time
when I set the agenda
you